สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะทุกๆ
คนขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่ห้องเรียน
comprehensive  Thai ห้องเรียนภาษาไทย
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็ในวันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครู
ชิเเนี่ยมาพบกับทุกๆคนอีกแล้วนะคะนะหลัง
จากเราไม่ได้เจอกันนานวันนี้วันอะไรแล้ว
คะครูชิวันนี้วันพระพฤหัสสบดีค่ะนะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะ 18 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนมกราคม
หรือมกราคมก็ได้อืค่ะเป็นเดือนที่เท่า
ไหร่คะ 1 ค่ะนะปีแบบไทยนะพุทธศักราชที่
เท่าไหร่คะ
2567  7  7 อ้าทำไม 7 เยอะจังคูชิอ๋อขอ
โทษค่ะคือดีดีใจไงว่า 66 ไปแล้วตอนเเนี่ย
67 แล้วใช่ค่ะ 2567 แล้วแล้วก็ปีแบบ
คริสตศักราชรอคะ
2024 ค่ะค่ะวันนี้ครู่ปุ๊กกับครูชิมาพบ
กับทุกๆคนนะคะในวันพฤหัสสดีวันที่ 18
เดือนมกราคมนะปีพุทธศักราชหรือว่าพ.ศ
2566  67 นะแล้วก็ปีคริสตศักราชหรือค.ศ
2024 ค่ะ
อืวันนี้เนี่ยได้ยินข่าวค่ะไม่สบายใจอไม่
สบายใจอะไรครูชิครูปุ๊กเนี่ยดูข่าวทุกวัน
รู้สึก
ไม่ไม่สบายใจนานแล้วค่ะทุกวัน
ค่ะคือเราจะเห็นว่าแบบบางทีเนี่ยเราทำ
อาหารหรือบางทีแม่ค้าที่ขายของแล้วไม่
ระมัดระวังอ่ะแล้วมันเกิด
อุบัติเหตุนะโอ๊ยครูชินี่เลยค่ะครูปุ๊ก
เพิ่งดูข่าวมาข่าวนึงค่ะอเป็นข่าวน่ากลัว
เหมือนกันแต่ว่านักเรียนไม่ต้องกลัวนะก็
เอาไว้เป็นเหมือนไว้เตือนตัวเองภาษาเรียน
ภาษา 1 เรียนภาษาไทย 2 ก็คือเป็น
อุบัติเหตุของคนอื่นเนาะเราก็เก็บเอาไว้
แล้วเราก็จะได้ระวังไงนะเอาไว้สอนตัวเอง
เวลาเราไปเจอเราก็จะได้แบบเอออันนี้เคยมี
คนเกิดอุบัติเหตุแบบนี้จะได้ไม่เหมือนไม่
ไม่ทำเหมือนเขคต้องระวังมากกว่าเคอือคือ
อย่างงี้ครูชิแล้วแบบเราเนเราก็เป็นผู้
หญิงเราเป็นแม่เนี่ยเราก็จะรู้สึกแบบ
โอ้โหอุบัติบัติเหตุที่เกิดกับเด็กๆตัว
เล็กๆเนี่ยน่าสงสารมากเป็นเด็กผู้หญิง
หรือผู้ชายคะเป็นเด็กผู้ชายค่ะูชิ
แล้วอายุเท่าไหร่อายุ 2 ขวบหรือว่า 2 ปี
นะ 2 ขวบพฤหัดเดินยังแบบเราเรียกว่าเดิน
เตาะแตะเตาะแตะยังไม่แข็งแรงมากใช่ค่ะแต่
อุบัติเหตุเนี้ยเกิดจากความ
ประมาทของคุณแม่ค่ะเกิดจากคุณแม่มากกว่า
ค่ะคุณแม่ประมาทเกิดอะไรขึ้นคืออย่างงี้
เขาบอกว่ามี
เอ่อผู้หญิงคนนึงนะแล้วก็ผู้หญิงคนเนี้ย
เค้าก็มีลูกนะเดี๋ยวนะรู้ยว่าผู้หญิงคน
นี้อายุเท่าไหร่ครูชิช่วยมั้ยอ่าไม่ต้อง
ค่ะ
ครูชิมีงูมาได้ยัง
ไงครูบุ๊กก็ได้ครููชิคือผู้หญิงคนนี้
เนี่ยนะเค้าเนี่ยแต่งงานใช่มย
ค่ะนะแล้วสามีเนี่ยเค้าก็มีพี่ชายอื
นะผู้เอ่อเอ้าไม่ใช่ขอโทษค่ะเป็นพี่ชาย
ของผู้หญิงคนนี้อ่าอ่าแล้วคนเแหละที่เา้า
มีลูกเมีลูกสาว 1 คนลูกชาย 1 คนขึ้นนิด
นึงนะลูกสาวเนี่ยอายุ 4 ขวบ
อ่าลูกชายเนี่ย 2 ขวบค่ะนะอแล้วก็ผู้หญิง
คนเนี้ยเค้ามีพี่ชายพี่ชายพี่ชายเนี่ย
แต่งงานอืใช่มั้ยแตนแดนแๆพี่ชายเนี่ยแต่ง
งานก็คนเนี้ยที่แต่งงานมาเป็นผู้หญิงเรา
เรียกสะใภ้เนาะแต่งงานกับพี่ก็เป็นพี่
สะใภ้อืนะพี่สะใภ้เนี่ยค่ะนะเค้ามี
อาชีพ
นะขายของทอดๆอ่ะค่ะนะเหมือนๆนักเรียนของ
ทอดอย่างเช่นเฟรนช์ฟรายใช่มยเวลา
เฟรนช์ฟรายก็ต้องทอด KFC ไก่ทอดอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะอื้อหือนะพี่สาวเนี่ยก็ขายของที่
เป็นของที่ทอดค่ะอือหือนะเค้าก็ต้องมี
กระทะใช่มยใช่ค่ะนะเพราะว่าของทอดเนี่ย
ต้องมีกระทะแล้วก็ต้องมีน้ำมันนะมากๆนัก
เรียนก็จะใช้เป็นน้ำมันปาล์มเนาะน้ำมันพม
น้ำมันปาล์มเนี่ยนะแล้วก็เค้าไม่ได้เตี้ย
ขนาดนี้ค่ะูชิเพราะว่าเค้าเนี่ยไม่ได้ข
ขายที่บ้านค่ะเคไปขายที่ตลาดค่ะนะเพราะ
ว่าไม่ได้ขายในซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
นะแต่เป็นแบบตลาดคนไทยอ่ะเขาคก็มีเป็นเตา
แก๊สค่ะสูงนิดนึงมีรถ
เข็นคิดว่าเ้าตั้งกับพื้นค่ะูชิอ๋อตั้ง
กับพื้นเหรอคะใช่เป็นขาตั้งที่ตั้งกับ
พื้นแล้วก็มีสัสายยางใช่มยนะสายของแก๊ส
แล้วก็นะมีถัง
แก๊สใช่ค่ะนะก็พี่สะใภ้นะนี้คุณแม่ใช่มย
อันนี้พี่
สะใภ้พี่สะใภ้เนี่ยค่ะก็มีอาชีพเนี่ยขาย
ของที่ทอดๆนะทอดก็ต้องมีน้ำมันแบบเละค่ะ
เฟรนช์ฟรายก็มันฝรั่งทอดนะใช่มั้ยอื
อันเนี้ยเขาคก็ขายเป็นไก่ทอดนะลูกชิ้นนะ
ทอดเนี่ยของทอดนะแล้วก็อคุณแม่เนี่ยก็คิด
ว่าเอ้ยเดี๋ยวไปซื้อนะของทอดที่พี่สะใภ้
ขายดีกว่านะอ่าใช่มั้ยชิ้นใช่เพราะว่าเอา
มาให้ลูกกินให้สามีกินอก็เลยให้สามีเนี่ย
ดูลูกสาวคนโตอืนะตัวเค้าเองเนี่ยก็พาลูก
ชายไปด้วยค่ะ
อ่าเพราะว่าลูกชายเนี่ยนะก็ไปด้วยกันกับ
คุณแม่อืทีนี้เนี่ยพอไปถึงตลาดเนี่ยก็คุย
กับพี่สะใภ้ใช่มั้ย
ค่ะแล้วคือพี่สะใภ้เนี่ยคนเนี้ยก็มีเค้า
มี 2 คนเนี่ยแต่งงานแล้วก็มีลูกสาว
อืม
คนนะลูกสาวเนี่ยยังไม่ถึง 2 ขวบค่ะ 1 ขวบ
กว่าๆอืแล้วพี่สะใภ้เนี่ยเอาลูกเนี่ยไว้
ที่
เก้าอี้นะคิดว่าเป็นเก้าอี้แบบพลาสติกอ่ะ
ค่ะออให้ลูกนั่งอยู่บนเก้าอี้พลาสติกใช่
ลูกสาวก็อยู่บนเก้าอี้แต่เด็กๆอนะเด็กๆ
เนี่ยจะนั่งเฉยๆมั้ยคะครูชิไม่เฉยค่ะอ่า
ก็จะสนหยิบนู่นหยิบนี่ซนไปเรื่อยๆนั่น
แหละพี่สะใภ้ก็เลยให้อยู่บนเก้าอี้เพื่อ
เด็กคนเนี้ยจะได้ไม่ต้องหยิบอะไรใช่มยอื
นะตัวเองก็เตรียมน้ำมันแล้วก็เอาน้ำมัน
เนี่ยแล้วก็เปิดแก๊สเพราะว่าจะทำของทอด
แล้วเนาะอือหือเคก็เตรียมน้ำน้ำมันน้ำมัน
ก็กำลังร้อนเลยแล้วก็เอาของลง
ไปทอดนะ
อเป็นกระทะแบบนี้แล้วก็เอาของทอดเนี่ยใส่
ไปในน้ำมัน
แล้วเดือดแบบึดๆๆๆๆอ่าพอคนเนี้ยพาลูกชาย
มาใช่มยคุณแม่เนี่ยพาลูกชายมาก็คุยกับพี่
สะใภ้แล้วก็บอกว่าอ่ะเอาลูกชิ้นเอาไก่เอา
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยเนาะพอคุยกันก็เคก็รอรอ
เสร็จแล้วเนี่ยปรากฏว่าตัวเล็กลูกสาวของ
คนเนี้ยค่ะของพี่สะใภ้เนี่ยเค้า
ปีนแล้วกำลังจะตกลงมาจากเก้าอี้ค่ะกำลัง
จะหล่นจาก
เก้าอี้คุณแม่เนี่ยที่กำลังจูงลูกชายอุ้ม
ลูกชายอยู่เนี่ยด้วยด้วยความตกใจค่ะก็เลย
เหมือนวางลูกชายลงแล้วก็ไปจับเด็กลูกลูก
ของพี่สะใภ้อ่ะค่ะนะอแต่พอปล่อยลงไปเนี่ย
ลูกชายเนี่ยยังยืนไม่ไม่โอเคแข็งแรงเออ
เขาก็เลยเหมือนเดินแบบเซแล้วก็ล้มพอจะล้ม
เนี่ยมือเนี่ยก็ไปจับเอาสายแก๊ส
อ๋ออ่าสเมื่อสักครู่นี้ออใช่สายแก๊สที่
ท่อส่งแก๊สเนี่ยพอจับปุ๊บมันก็เลยดึงเา
แก๊สกระทะร้อนๆนะมีน้ำมันร้อนๆเนี่ยมันก็
เลยหกเอียงลงมาแล้วก็หกแล้วก็ราดตัวของ
เด็กผู้ชาย 2 ขวบใช่ค่ะอืเห็นมั้ยคุณแม่
เนี่ยไปช่วยเด็กอีกคนนึงแต่ปล่อยลูกตัว
เองช่วยออ่าแล้วลูกตัวเองเนี่ยยังยืนไม่
ดีไงพอรีบเใช่มั้ยวางปุ๊บก็รีบไปช่วยแต่
แต่เด็กอ่ะเซแล้วก็ล้มแล้วก็เลยจับสาย
แก๊สมันก็เลยดึงพอล้มปุ๊บมันก็เลยดึงเตา
แก๊สเนี่ยนะกระทะลงมาเลยอ่าใช่กระทะก็เลย
คว่ำลงมาใส่
ตัวนักเรียนแล้วน้ำมันนะคะไม่ใช่น้ำน้ำ
ร้อนถ้าน้ำร้อนเนี่ยเดือดเนี่ย 100 องน้ำ
มันเดือดนี่ประมาณ 200 องศานะโอ้โหโดนนี่
แบบเนื้อสุกนะ
อ่าแต่ว่ารูปเนาะเราก็จะได้รูปมาที่แบบ
ไม่ค่อยจะชัดเท่าไหร่เพราะว่าเขาต้องเบลอ
รูปไว้นะก็จะเป็นลักษณะแบบนี้ค่ะอันนี้
เป็นผู้ใหญ่ให้ดูได้อันนี้โดนน้ำมัน
เหมือนกันออนี้อันนี้ไม่ใช่ขาของเด็กที่
โดนนะอันนี้เป็นขาผู้ใหญ่ที่โดนน้ำมันเอา
มาให้ดูใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าอันนี้น้ำร้อนเน้ำ
ร้อนมันจะพองแบบนี้ถ้าน้ำมันเนี่ยโอ้โห
หนังจะแบบหนังหายใช่ค่ะุนึกถึงไก่อ่ะเออ
มันจะหดเวลาลงไปแล้วหนังมันหดอ่ะหนังมัน
จะยู่ลงนะมันจะหดเนี้ยของเด็กคนเนี้ยค่ะ
นะเ้าจะจรเอาไว้ใช่ค่ะเขาจะเบลอภาพไม่ให้
เห็น 100% เพราะว่ามันมันเหมือนหนังอ่ะ
มันจะหดตัวค่ะมันจะดึงลั้งขึ้นมาอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะแล้วก็ยืดไม่ได้ใช่เนี่ยค่ะช่วง
บริเวณเนี้ยที่เป็นแล้วก็มีช่วงตัวค่ะ
เนี่ยค่ะถ้าเราเห็นในภาพโอ้โหโหเด็ก 2
ขวบ 2 ขวบแล้วก็โดนทั้งขาด้วยทั้งตัวด้วย
ลงมาถึงขาอ่อนเนี่ยข้างบนเนาะ
นะเยอะมากค่ะ
นะแล้วก็รักษามาแล้วเนี่ยก็คือ 8 เดือนนะ
เนี่ยได้แค่เนี้ยค่ะ 8 เดือน 8 เดือนยัง
ไงก็เป็นก็กลายเป็นแผเป็นแผ่เป็นแน่นอน
ค่ะูชินะเพราะว่าเริ่มจากการที่เป็นแผล
ก่อนนะที่เป็นตุ่มพองใสๆแล้วก็มีน้ำข้าง
ในพอมันยุบมันแตกเนี่ยนะมันก็กลายเป็นแผล
มีเลือดซิบๆเนาะเจ็บนะแล้วก็พอแผลเนี่ย
มันดีขึ้นนะมันหายมันแห้งแล้วนะไม่มีน้ำ
แล้วมันแห้งแล้วมันก็กลายเป็นแเป็นแน่นอน
ค่ะนะอือหือแล้ว 2 ขวบอ่ะน่าสงสารเนาะอนะ
แล้วพอดีว่าวันเสาร์ที่แล้วไงเสาร์ที่
ผ่านมาเป็นวันเด็ก
อืมคุณแม่ก็เลยไปขอร้องแบบโอโหช่วยด้วยนะ
ช่วยลูกด้วยเพราะว่ากลัวลูกเนี่ยจะเป็น
แบบแผลแผลเป็นอย่างเงี้ยแล้วก็ตรงขาเนี่ย
เนาะเด็กผู้ชายขานะขาที่ไปถึงเท้าอ่ะมัน
มันยึดมันต้องผ่าตัดแล้วถ้าทำไม่ดีไม่สวย
ไม่โอเคไงไม่อืก็เลยไปหนังสือพิมพ์ไปหลาย
ที่เนาะแล้วก็พยามให้ช่วยลูกใช่ก็มีโรง
พยาบาลที่ทำเกี่ยวกับพลาสติกเซอร์เจอรี่
หรือว่าศัลยกรรมเนาะนะก็โรงพยาบาลยันฮี
เขาก็เลยบอกว่าโอเคเช่วยนะดีค่ะูชิออดี
มากก็ก็โชคดีที่มีโรงพยาบาลที่แบบเป็น
สปอนเซอร์ให้นะช่วยเหลือเด็กคนนี้ 2 ขวบ
นะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่ามีผู้หญิงคนนึงเนี่ยที่
เขาดูแลเรื่องเด็กๆอ่ะคุณปวีนาเนี่ยเขาก็
พาไปที่โรงพยาบาลยันฮีโรงพยาบาลก็เลยบอก
ว่าโอเคเขารับดูแลให้ไม่คิดเงินนะโรง
พยาบาลนี้มีชื่อเสียงในเรื่องของการผ่า
ตัดเปลี่ยนนะคะเปลี่ยนให้สวยขึ้นหน้าให้
สวยนะเพราะฉะนั้นเด็กคนนี้เนี่ยอาจจะโดน
น้ำร้อนอาจจะต้องไปเอาส่วนไหนมาติดอ่ามา
มาแก้ไขอใช่ค่ะนะก็เลยเอามาเล่าให้ฟังว่า
เด็กคนเนี้ยอนาคตเนาะพอแผลหายแล้วเนี่ยนะ
จากเป็นแผลแล้วแผลหายก็จะเป็นแผลเป็นนะ
แล้วแผลเป็นอันเนี้ยมันจะติดไปตลอดเลยนะ
นะชีวิตนี้ทั้งชีวิตแต่เค้ายังโชคดีกว่า
สมัยสมัยเอ่อพวกเรานะเพราะว่าสมัยเรา
เนี่ยเป็นแผ่เป็นเนี่ยมันจะเป็นตลอดเลย
แต่ตอนเนี้ยเทคโนโลยีมันดีขึ้นนะคะสามารถ
แก้ไขปัญหาของแผลเป็นได้นะคะแต่ถ้าเราพูด
ถึงแผลเป็นเนี่ยมันก็จะเป็นแผลเป็นประเภท
ที่แบบว่าเนี่ยที่บอกว่าเป็นแผลมันอาจจะ
เกิดจากการเอ่อมีมีบาดแผลแล้วแล้วก็เย็บ
ไม่ดีจนกลายเป็นแผลแบบลักษณะแบบนี้นะนะ
ค่ะหรือหรือเราบอกว่าแผลเป็นพวกเนี้ยนะ
อาจจะเป็นแบบอันเนี้ยเป็นเหมือนกับที่แบบ
ครูุบอกโดนความร้อนโดนน้ำร้อนรวกนะคะแล้ว
พอหายเนี่ยแผลมันก็จะเป็นอยู่นะคมันก็จะ
กลายเป็นแผลเป็นเนื้อมันจะสีไม่เท่ากัน
มันจะกระดำกระดาษนะคะแล้วก็อันนี้เนี่ย
เกิดจากแผลที่เกิดน้ำร้อเอ่อลวกแล้วมัน
มันย่นแบบเนี้ยนะหนังมันถูกดึงให้มันแบบ
ยึดนะมันหดตัวมั้ยูชิเหมือนหนักตัวอ่ะมัน
ดึงขึ้นมาอย่างเงี้ยใช่อันนี้คือรักษา
แล้วนะแต่ตอนที่เป็นแรกๆนี่โอ้โหนึกถึง
เวลาที่โดนแล้วแบบหนังมันหดหดมันดึงล้าง
ขึ้นมาเนี่ยมันจะยึดแบบโอ้โหยึดมากๆอัน
นี้เนี่ยโดนไม่เยอะเะนะครูปุ๊กเคยเห็นคน
ที่โดนด้วยเคโดนที่แขนไงที่นี่มันหดเา้า
ก็เลยต้องติดเลยติดอย่างงี้เลยค่ะมัน
เหมือนเป็นทางขืดที่เนี่ยล็อคไว้เลยค่ะ
แล้วก็ยืดยืดแขนออกมาแบบอย่างนี้ไม่ได้
ยืดออกไม่ได้มันติด
นะเ้ารอโตขึ้นแล้วก็ไปผาตัดแล้วก็ยืดออก
มาได้ออมันโดนลวกจนแบบหนังมาติดกันเลยอ่ะ
ใช่ใช่ค่ะก็เพราะว่าตอนสมัยก่อนน่ะ
เทคโนโลยียังไม่ดีไงครูปุ๊กใช่ค่ะนะ
ปัจจุบันเนี่ยถ้าเกิดคุณเป็นแผลเป็นแบบ
สมัยก่อนแบบเนี้ยนะที่แบบนูนออกมาแบบ
เนี้ยเป็นแผลเป็นแบบ
นูนนะตอนนี้เมีเลเซอร์มีการรักษาแผลมีการ
ปรับสีเหมือนๆกับเด็กคนเนี้ยเกิดใน
2567 ใช่มั้ยปัจจุบันเทคโนยีมันดีขึ้นนะ
คะการที่แบบไปตัดเนื้อที่อื่นแล้วมา
แปะใช่สมัยก่อนไม่มีอเออสีมันก็ไม่ค่อย
เหมือนกันเนาะแต่มันก็ยังดีเ้ามีเลเซอร์
ด้วยเดี๋ยวเนี้ยใช่มยเลเซอร์ที่ทำปรับสี
ให้มันเท่ากันนะก็จะทำให้มองไม่เห็นแผล
เป็น
อซึ่งแผ่เป็นเนี่ยมันก็จะเกิดมาจากหลายๆ
สาเหตุเนาะ
นะเพราะว่าอย่างบางคนเนี่ยอย่างโดนน้ำมัน
โดนน้ำร้อนอหรือบางคนอาจจะไปดผ่าตัดอือ่า
เวลาบางคนท้องใช่มั้ยท้องแล้วก็คลอดเอง
ไม่ได้อื้อหือก็อาจจะต้องผ่าตัดนะพอผ่า
ตัดเนี่ยแผลผ่าตัดบางทีก็น่ากลัวเนาะูชิ
น่ากลัวค่ะเพราะมันผ่าตัดมันใช้
เอ่อการเย็บบางบางทีแผลแผลผาตัดยาวโหยไป
เห็นในอินเทอร์เน็ตนะคะแล้วก็ดูแล้วเนี่ย
โอ๊ยน่ากลัวมากอ่ะค่ะเป็นแบบนี้เลยแผนนูน
แบบที่ครูชี้บอกอ่ะนะอันนี้คือแผลเป็น
เพราะว่ามันเริ่มจะนะเค้าผ่าก็เป็นแผลใช่
มยคุณหมอผ่าแล้วเป็นแผลแล้วก็เย็บค่ะดู
รอยเข็มยังอยู่เลยค่ะนะแล้วก็แผลเนี่ย
เป็นแผลนูนแล้วโอ้โหแล้วผ่าแบบเนี้ยนะน่า
จะหายยากนะครูชิเพราะว่าูอืจะเป็นแผลเป็น
ที่เห็นชัดใช่นะเคยเห็นที่แบบโดนผ่าตัด
แบบนี้ก็มีใช่มยอือันเนี้ย
แผลเป็นแบบเนี้ยยังสวยนะูชิถ้าเทียบกับ
เมื่อกี้นะเพราะว่าเวลาอ้วนแล้วมันอาจจะ
เป็นเหมือนกับชั้นของไข
มันเป็นชั้นๆของของท้องใช่มั้ยอือ่า
เดี๋ยวนี้เนี่ยเค้าผ่าตัดเนี่ยถ้าคุณหมอ
ผ่าตัดเนี่ยส่วนมากเค้าก็จะผ่าแบบถ้าแบบ
เกี่ยวกับท้องนะอย่างตัดมดลูกข้างในนะ
เขาคก็จะผ่าแบบบิกินนี่ลายเพื่อให้มันดู
สวยงามไม่ไม่ได้เป็นแผลแบบแผลแบบผ่าตรง
แบบนี้ไงนะเพราะว่าพอเป็นบิกินี่ LINE
เนี่ยถึงเวลาเป็นแผลเป็นเนาะมันก็ดูยัง
โอเคนะใ่บิกินนี่ได้ค่ะอืให้ให้เป็นลาย
ตามขวางแบบนี้นะไม่ใช่แบบพาตามแบบแล้ว
สมัยก่อนเย็บอ่ะจริงๆนะครูปุ๊กเหมือนกับ
คุณหมอเย็บแล้วเนี่ยมันมันจะมีรอยที่หรือ
ว่ามันก็จะมี 2 สาเหตุนะอาจจะเป็นเพราะ
ว่าคนไข้เองเนี่ยดูแลแผลไม่ดีหรือกิน
อาหารที่บางทีมันทำให้มีแบคทีเรียมันทำ
ให้แผลมันบวม
ขึ้นมาได้
นะบางคนบอกว่าห้ามกินไข่ด้วยูชิปุ๊ก็ไม่
รู้นะว่าแต่ตอนคุณบุ๊กผ่าตัดคุณบุ๊กก็กิน
ไข่นะมันก็ไม่เห็นนูนขึ้นมานะนะคือมัน
ขึ้นอยู่กับว่าแต่ละคนแผ้อาหารอะไรไงมีผล
กับอะไรอย่างเช่นบางคนกินอาหารทะเลแล้วก็
ทำให้แผลอักเสบแต่บางคนกินก็ไม่เป็นอะไรอ
นะหรือบางคนบอกว่าไปกินของดองอ่ะของหมัก
ดองที่น้ำเกลือเออดองแบบเนี้ยมันอาจจะมี
แบคทีเรียที่มันไปทำให้แผลที่มันมีปัญหา
อยู่มันอักเสบมากขึ้นอืนะคมันก็เลยทำให้
แผลมันอักเสบก็คือมันจะบวมขึ้นแล้วเป็นสี
แดงแล้วบางทีก็เป็นน้ำสีเหลืองๆก็คือหนอง
อันนั้นใชนะแล้วแน่นอนพอมันเป็นแบบเนี้ย
ธรรมชาติของร่างกายเราอ่ะมันก็จะสร้าง
อะไรที่มามาเสริมอ่ะเพราะว่ามันมีมันมี
เซลล์ที่ตายอยู่มันก็จะมาแบบมาเพิ่มแต่
มันเพิ่มมากเกินไปมันมันก็กลายเป็นแผล
เป็นนะแล้วก็นูนขึ้นมาด้วยใช่อันนี้ก็ไม่
สวยเลยเนาะยูชิูชิเคยเป็นแผลเป็นที่แบบ
ว่ามันถูกบาตรแต่ครูชิเนี่ยไม่ไปเย็บเอ้า
ทีนี้มันอยู่ที่หัวเข่าอหัวเข่าหัว
เข่าตงหัวเข่ามันจะเป็นแบบข้อพับไงตรงหัว
เข่าอ่ะมันจะเหมือนกับเป็นข้อพับแบบเนี้ย
เข่ามันแบบเวลาเราเดินใช่มยเวลาที่เรา
เดินเนี่ยมันก็จะมีเข่าที่แบบใช่มั้ยมัน
งอได้อ่ะบางทีเรานั่งนะคเวลานั่งเนี่ยมัน
เข่ามันก็จะงอใช่มั้ยอือฮึเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยแผลเนี่ยมันไม่มันมันไม่ประสานกัน
แบบนี้อันนี้เรียกว่าสารใช่มั้ยมันกลาย
เป็นแบบบางทีมันก็เปิดพอเปิดแล้วเนี่ยมัน
ก็สร้างเซลล์ใหม่ขึ้นมามันก็ทำให้เกิด
เป็นแผลเป็นอย่างที่อย่างที่เห็นไงมันก็
เลยแบบนูนขึ้นมา
นะเพราะว่ามันมันประสานกันไม่ดีใช่มั้ย
มันก็จะเป็นแผเป็นแบบนี้
นี่มันเหมือนกับซัส้างขึ้นมาเพิ่มเป็นที่
หัวเข่าเหรอค่ะใช่ค่ะเท้าใช่แล้วก็ขาแล้ว
ก็อันเนี้ยค่ะหัวเข่านะเพราะเวลาเรานั่ง
ไงมันจะงออยู่เรื่อยๆใช่มั้ยงอนึกถึงภาพ
ที่แบบเข่างออย่างเงี้ยตรงเนี้ยมันก็
เหมือนกับเนื้อมันขยายไงแผลมันโดนแผลแบบ
นี้ใช่มยพอมันจะปิดอ่ะพอพอเรายืดเข่ามัน
ก็ขยายแบบนี้มันก็เลยสร้างเซลล์ขึ้นมามัน
ก็เลยกลายเป็นแผลเป็นอ่ะครูปุ๊กอือ๋อนะก็
เป็นแผลเป็นครูชิมีที่เข่าเหรอคะใช่ค่ะมี
ที่เข่าเพราะว่าูชิเนี่ยเกิดจากเอ่อไปไป
นั่งเรือไงครูชิทำงานกับเรือใช่มยแล้วใต้
ท้องเรือครูปุ๊กมันมีมันมี
เพียงเนี่ยมันมีอันเนี้ย
โอ้โหซุเปอร์คมค่ะมันบา
มันติดอยู่มันติดอยู่ใต้ท้องเรือเรือใช่
มั้ยแล้วมีเพียงพวกเนี้ยอยู่ใต้ท้องเรือ
ค่ะอืออันนี้เรือแบบไททานิค
นะเรือไม่ไม่เป็นเหมือนกับ
เรือเรือพายแบบกรรเชียงอ่ะ
อ๋อเงี้แล้วก็มีเพียงที่เกาะอยู่ใต้ท้อง
เรือเพราะว่าเรือเนี่ยมันจะแช่นน้ำนาน
อื้อหือแล้วครูชิก็กระโดดลงน้ำว่ายน้ำ
เสร็จจะปีนขึ้นข้างบนไงอืแล้วเวลายกขา
ขึ้นน่ะออก็เลยเป็นยกขาก้าวขึ้นมามันก็
เลยที่หัวเข่าออโอ้โหเลือดออกสิคะอย่าง
เงี้ยโอ้โหหมดขนมปังค่ะจริงๆมีขนมปังจะไป
ให้ปลาค่ะปรากฏว่าขนมขมปังมาปิดแผลเพราะ
ว่าเลือด
ไหลโอปลาได้กินเลือดไปด้วยเนาะนะใช่อ่ะ
ของพอหัวเข่าครูชี้เนี่ยใช่
มยหัวเข่าเนี่ยเป็นแผลปึ๊บตรงนี้นะคะ
เลือดไหลแบบโอ้โห
แบบเพราะว่าเพิ่งขึ้นมาจากน้ำไงูกุ๊ก
เลือดแบบเยอะ
มากขนมปังอ่ะไม่มีสำลีไม่มีทิชชู่ไม่
มีขนมปังแซนวิชแซนวิช
เนี่ยขนมปังเนี่ย 1 แผ่น 2 แผ่นเปลี่ยน
เป็นสีแดง
ออเลือดเต็มไปหมดเลยอ้าแล้วตอนนี้ก็เลย
เป็นแผลเป็นสิใช่ค่ะเป็นแผลเป็นที่หัว
เข่ายาวมยูชิ
ประมาณ
นิ้ว
เซมประมาณนิ้วครึ่งอ่า 1 นิ้วครึ่งใช่ค่ะ
นะก็อันนี้ของครูชินะยาวเหมือนกันนะครูชิ
นะแผลเป็นไใช่ค่ะ
นะแต่ของครูปุ๊กเนี่ยครูปุ๊กก็มีแผ่เป็น
เหมือนกันนะอ้าูปึมีแผเป็นที่ไหน
ถ้าถ้าทำเองเนี่ยที่แบบไอ้เนี่ยก็จะเป็น
ที่คางค่ะูชิหาที่คางเนี่ยหรอใช่ค่ะที่
คางเนี่ยค่ะนะเพราะว่าตอนเด็กๆเนาะมันจะ
เป็นลักษณะแผเป็นลักษณะแบบนี้ค่ะคางกระท
คางแตกใช่ค่ะเหมือนเด็กคนนี้เลยเหรออร Cut
ไม่ใช่
ค่ะครูปุ๊กเนี่ยนะ
เอ่อดูทีวีดูโทรทัศน์ค่ะนะแล้วที่ดู
โทรทัศน์ใช่ที่โทรทัศน์เนี่ยจะมีทาซานนะ
นักเรียนไม่รู้จักทาซานรู้จักป่ะไม่รู้นะ
ที่เป็นเด็กแล้วก็เกิดในป่ามีกอริล่าใช่
มั้ยแล้วก็เลี้ยงเแล้วก็ทาซานเนี่ยอยู่
กับลิงเจี๊ยกจๆๆๆใช่มยแล้วก็ทุกวันเนี่ย
ก็ปีนต้นไม้เก่งนะเพราะว่าลิงก็ปีนต้นไม้
เก่งนะแล้วก็ูชิครูชิรู้จักทาซานูปุ๊กนี่
ๆครูชิเปิดให้ดูทาซาน
อ่าใช่เลยคุณดูชิแล้วทาซานเนี่ยมีเห็น
มั้ยที่มือเนี่ยเป็นเถาวันเป็นต้นไม้ใช่
มยแล้วก็ไม้เนี่ยเลื้อยนะทาซานก็จะโหนแถว
วันเนี่ย่ะค่ะว้า
ทั้งวันโออ่าใช่ค่ะนะครูบุ๊กก็โอ้โห
โหหล่อ
มากก็เลยคิดก๊อปปี้ทาซานค่ะ
อ้าูปุ๊กก็เลยที่บ้านเนี่ยมีต้นไม้ใช่มย
ค่ะมีต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้เนี่ยอือแล้วก็
เลยเอาเชือกเนี่ยไปผูกไว้ค่ะอืจะได้โหน
แบบทาซานใช่นะครูปุ๊กเนี่ยตัวเล็กๆใช่
มั้ยเพราะว่าเด็กนะ
ก็จับแล้วก็โหนไง
โ
อื้อหือเสร็จแล้วนะเชือกเนี่ยมันหลุดมือ
ค่ะเพราะว่าพอสุดปลายเชือกเนี่ยมันก็หลุด
ออกไปครูปุ๊กก็ลอยไปเลยค่ะอันนี้ไม่ได้
เป็นทาซานแล้วค่ะเป็นม้าใช่มั้ยโอ้แล้วก็
หลุดนักเรียนพอเวลาเราจับเชือกใช่มยแล้ว
พอเหวี่ยงไปเนี่ยมัน
รืดเชือกมันก็
ไหลครูปุ๊กก็หลุดออกจากเชือกใช่ค่ะแล้วก็
ไปเจอแบบสะพานค่ะสะพานที่เราเดินข้ามน้ำ
อ่ะนะใช่ค่ะคาูก็เอาทางไปชนสะพานใช่ค่ะ
เหาะไปเนี่ย
โอก็เลยแตก
ใช่แตกเลยค่ะที่
นี่เป็นแผลเป็นใช่แล้วก็ครูปุ๊กก็เลยแบบ
กลัวคุณพ่อคุณแม่รู้ใช่มยนะก็ไม่บอกค่ะ
เพราะว่าเราซนนะเดี๋ยวจะโดนตีอืครูก็ไม่
บอกก็เลยไปที่ที่ที่กระจกแล้วก็ดูตัวเอง
อู้หูคูชิเป็นแบบนี้นะเป็นรูนอืเหมือน
เด็กคนเนี้ยคอืเด็กเมื่อกี้ที่ครูบุ๊ก
โชว์รูปรภาพให้ดูอ่ะนะแล้วก็มีเลือดนะไม่
ไหลแบบูชินะูชิเนี่ยเลือดออกเยอะๆใช่มย
แต่ว่าคุกเนี่ยเลือดแค่ซึมๆออกมานิดหน่อย
แล้วก็มีทิชชู่แล้วก็ทิชชู่
ซับนิดหน่อยแล้วก็ดูเโอ้โหสีเหลืองค่ะไข
มันคอเลสเตอรอลแล้วก็เช็ดตอนนี้ก็เป็นแผล
เป็นเล็กๆค่ะอ่าไม่ใหญ่เล็กๆไม่ใหญ่อืใช่
อันนี้ก็เป็นแผลเป็นที่ครูปุ๊กค่ะมีตั้ง
แต่เด็กๆเลยค่ะเห็นมั้นักเรียนวันนี้
เนี่ยนักเรียนก็รู้จักนะแผลเป็นเป็นยังไง
ใช่ค่ะแผลเป็นเนี่ยเกิดจากอะไรออ่าแล้ว
ก่อนที่เราจะเป็นแผลเป็นเนี่ยเราต้องเป็น
แผลก่อนนะพอเป็นแผลแผลแห้งแล้วหายแล้วแต่
มันจะเป็นลอยอยู่นะเราเรียกว่าแผลเป็นอ่ะ
สลับกันนะเป็นแผลก่อนแล้วหลังจากนั้นหาย
แล้วก็จะเป็นแผลเป็นค่ะอ่าไม่ใช่แผลตาย
อ้านะมันยังไม่หายไงมันถ้ามันหายเนี่ยมัน
ก็จบมันยังเป็นอยู่ไงมันยังไม่หายมันยัง
เป็นแผลยนานมาตลอดใช่เนาะวันนี้ก็หมดเวลา
แล้วค่ะูชิ
ถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยมีแผลเป็นตรงไหนแล้วอยาก
จะบอกเราก็คอมเมนต์มานะคะเราจะได้รู้ว่า
ระเล่าให้เราฟังใช่ครูปุ๊กกับนักเรียน
เนี่ยใครซนกว่ากันตอนเด็กๆเนาะเหมือน
ีโอเคเรามาพบกันใหม่ในคลิปต่อไปนะคะคลิป
นี้ก็สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะ